und heute wollen wir uns einem thema
widmen dass viele beschäftigt nicht das
virus an sich sondern die auswirkungen
auf die wirtschaft und die finanzen weil
die sind ja direkt die sind weltweit
ziemlich stark und das macht vielen
leuten sorgen ganz einfache fragen was
ist mit meinen ersparnissen was ist mit
meinem geld auf den banken ist es sicher
oder sollte ich jetzt zum beispiel
stichwort fallende kurse gerade jetzt in
aktien investieren
darüber möchte ich heute sprechen mit
der finanz blockerin natascha wegelin
die ist als madame moneypenny im netz
unterwegs gibt dort tipps für die
richtige anlage für die altersvorsorge
vor allem für frauen aber heute dürfen
auch männer fragen stellen hallo frau
wegelin also eure fragen zu dem großen
thema was passiert mit meinem geld mit
meinen ersparnissen wohlig das an was
sollte ich jetzt kaufen oder besser sein
lassen bitte in die kommentare posten
mich würde jetzt erst mal von ihnen
interessieren haben sie jetzt für ihre
gekauft oder haben sie wie ihre verkauft
ich habe tendenziell gekauft also ich
habe aktien gekauft etf so ein bisschen
was nach gekauft aber auch gar keinen
fall verkauft das wäre jetzt genau die
falsche strategie in diesem moment weil
jetzt gerade sind die kurse eher günstig
das heißt wenn ich jetzt verkaufen würde
würde ich das eventuell oder wie es
wahrscheinlich mit einem recht großen
verlust machen
also ich persönlich hab noch mal
nachgelegt und wenn die nächste zeit
auch mache das ganz spannend weil die
kurse sind ja entfallen warum darüber
sprechen wir gleich sind für alle die
erst eine tasche wegelin und der
projektmarkt moneypenny nicht kennen
gibt es hier eine kurze einführung soll
ich jetzt einsteigen oder noch warten
wann ist der beste zeitpunkt natascha
wegelin pisten finanz blogger sind sie
gibt ratschläge zur altersvorsorge und
aktienanlage unter dem namen madame
money bin
sie hat bwl studiert und 2012 mit einem
partner ein start-up gegründet 2017
verkaufte sie einen teil davon
seitdem will sie frauen ermutigen sich
selbst um ihre finanzen zu kümmern um
sich unabhängig zu machen
über facebook instagram youtube und
ihrem podcast zeigt sie schritt für
schritt wie vermögensaufbau gelingen
kann und die man sich langfristig
absichert ihre community zählt
inzwischen mehr als 70.000 mitglieder ja
eine menge leute die eine menge frage
haben ihr hoffentlich auch ich fange mal
mit neuen fragen an während eure fragen
so eintrudeln einfach mal so zum
grundsatz was es so ihre grundsatz
philosophie was anlegen und sparen
angeht
das relativ simple buy and hold also
passives anregen passives investieren
das bedeutet auf eine lange zeit
gestreckt sehr breit diversifiziert und
das risiko eben soweit wie möglich
runter zu schrauben und dann dieser
strategie treu bleiben das heißt hatte
ich ja schon angedeutet jetzt eben nicht
in panik zu verfallen würden schnell zu
verkaufen sondern meine strategie und
das ist auch was ich auf meinem blog so
kommunizieren und in einem podcast und
so weiter eine strategie überlegen bei
berthold ist das bei uns und dann auf
die nächsten zehn jahre halten und sich
von dem was jetzt gerade passiert so
wenig wie möglich beeindrucken lassen
kommt aus geldern aus den dividenden
also aus den ausschüttungen der
unternehmen mit den gewinnen oder davon
dass man das irgendwie in 20 jahren
alles auf den markt schmeißt und dann
hofft dass man über die 20 jahre 20
prozent gewinn gemacht hat
es geht natürlich beides ja man könnte
dividenden auch mitnehmen
unsere strategie oder das was ich eher
so verfolge ist tatsächlich wenn es
dividenden gibt die direkt wieder zu
reden bis 10 bei aktuell gibt es
eigentlich gar nicht darum geld zu
bekommen jetzt geld daraus zu ziehen
sondern das ist ja für die
altersvorsorge gedacht oder für
langfristigen vermögensaufbau also das
heißt die gewinne werden immer direkt
wieder reinvestiert und dann nach 20 30
jahren wie auch immer so mein ziel ist
war nicht vielleicht eine rente gehen
möchte wie das vermögen sozusagen
sukzessive wieder abgenommen und davon
kann ich dann im endeffekt leben ist von
der rente selbst gebauter rente aber
wenn wir jetzt mal auf den dax kurs
gucken ich habe ihn mir mal kurz hier
auf meinem monitor gelegt vielleicht
schalten die kollegen mal kurz darauf
das ist der verlauf der sechs monate
sodass gingen nach oben nach oben dann
oben nach oben und da hielt sie schon so
lange waren wir hier bei 13.000 660
punkten alle haben gefeiert und hier
sind wir abgerauscht und hier stehen wir
jetzt gerade so ein bisschen erholt
haben wir uns aber nicht so richtig viel
wieso passiert sowas wenn ihre strategie
doch sache relativ vernünftig klingt
erstmal nachhaltig kaufen nachhaltig
investieren wie kommt denn dann so eine
kurve zu stande
die kurve kommt ja so oder so zustande
also ich persönlich hab jetzt nicht in
den sechs investiert aber alle anderen
ihnen indizes gehen ja auch runter aber
da ist ja die frage okay was kann ich
denn dann tun in sohren der krise das
heißt da gibt es jetzt menschen die
sanyo ich verkaufe jetzt also so kommt
das zustande dass die kurse so schnell
steigern so schnell steigen und fallen
im aktuellen stand dann fallen dass ganz
viele menschen jetzt sagen okay ich
möchte das jetzt ganz ganz schnell
anscheinend verkaufen und das ist ein
herber trieb das ist ein panik fallen
das ist psychologie der massen wenn
einer anfängt und ob jetzt muss man
alles verkaufen oder wir müssen jetzt
alle klopapier kaufen hätte rennt die
leute quasi hinterher
das sind dann also die anleger anlegerin
die fläche nicht bald holt praktizieren
oder vielleicht auch zu viel ihres
geldes zu risikoreich investiert haben
und jetzt gerade merken oje ich brauche
aber doch eigentlich dieses geld und ich
verfalle gerade in panik und möchte so
schnell wie möglich wieder alles raus
ziehen um so kommen dann eben diese
verluste zustande unseren rollen der
effekt quasi dass die kurse immer weiter
fallen also vor allem psychologie ja es
ist rein und als psychologie ist es hat
ganz viel mit der wartung zu tun das
interessante ist ja also die börse ist
gerade der wirtschaft sehr weit voraus
denn die meisten unternehmen haben ja
noch gar nicht ihre zahlen so richtig
kommuniziert das kommt ja eigentlich
erst noch das heißt was jetzt gerade an
dem passiert ist dass die anleger
anlegerin investorinnen antizipieren was
passieren könnte was natürlich auch
durchaus begründet ist aber nur wenn man
das mal so auseinander dröselt
eigentlich so richtig ist noch nicht so
super viel passieren wir reagieren
natürlich jetzt stark auf nachrichten
und dann müssen wir noch mal sehen was
passiert wenn die unternehmen dann
wirklich ihre unternehmenszahlen aus q1
kommunizieren crans-montana ich nachher
genau aus dem letzten quartal aus
quartal 1 kommunizieren ob die börse
dann schon mal das mit eingepreist hat
oder gibts nochmal runter weil es noch
viel schlimmer ist als alle dachten oder
geht es wieder hoch weil alle ok so
schlimm ist dann jetzt jedoch gar nicht
geworden
also erstmal abwarten höre ich bei ihnen
raus geht's aber jetzt einen kommentar
zum beispiel auf facebook von olaf
nicholas carlson der schreibt jetzt in
akten ge aktien ging es hoch riskant am
ende kann es passieren dass die firma in
die ich mein geld gesteckt habe pleite
ist
also wir sehen ja zum beispiel alle
flugzeugbauer haben große probleme alle
autobauer haben große probleme
also hier die klare befürchtungen die
stecker geld rein und dann ist es weg
ist das realistisch das ist total ist
also da sind wir wieder bei der
risikoverteilung wenn ich jetzt sage
okay ich denke mal ein ganzes geld oder
auch einen großteil meines geldes meines
ersparten in ein zwei drei vier fünf
unternehmen oder in 23 verschiedenen
branchen die vielleicht jetzt eher
gebeutelt sind und bei denen ich nicht
daran glaube dass sie das noch mal
wieder schaffen oder gestärkt aus dieser
krise hervorgehen würde ich dann
natürlich dementsprechend nicht mal geld
investieren war aber eigentlich immer
eine ganz gute strategie ist ist so
breit wie möglich zu diversifizieren
also ich persönlich investieren nicht in
234 unternehmen sondern anhand von
sogenannten ets sind passive fonds über
2.000 unternehmen also in die komplette
gesamte weltwirtschaft und da ist der
ist der abfall dann nicht so extrem sind
jetzt die flug wenn ein surfer
weitergeht sind wir immer noch tausend
andere in diesem fall drin und das ist
ja nicht so ganz so schlimm ganz genau
ganz genau das risiko ist also viel
breiter verteilt auf verschiedene
schultern
hier gibt es jetzt eine frage von kai
kirchner auf youtube der möchte wissen
also auch die gleiche frage ist es jetzt
klug ist es nicht zu riskant
und wenn nicht welche aktien würden sie
empfehlen
sie haben gesagt das klingt für mich
immer so abstrakt geht es gibt es da
auch so labels oder wie informiert man
sich da am besten welche etf zu einem
passt also bei ets ist eigentlich
relativ simpel also das ist genau
passiver passive aktien fordern ganz
ganz viele verschiedene aktien drinnen
im besten fall und dann nehme ich mir am
besten gerade an größten also wenn man
sich so ein msi gold etf beispielsweise
anschaut da sind ca 1800 unternehmen aus
der ganzen welt drin also aus den
entwickelten märkten drin
schwellenländer gibt's auch ein etf
darauf das heißt das sind dann die
unternehmen aus schwellenländern und so
kann man sich dann was zusammen mixen
da will ich jetzt ungerne konkrete
empfehlung nachher alle koniferen der
tasche hat gesagt und jetzt gibt es den
bach runter aber ich denke wenn man sich
ein bisschen mit der krise krise
beschäftigt und auch schaut ok welche
branchen profitieren denn gerade es gibt
immer branchen und unternehmen die
aktuell profitieren sei es jetzt suchen
oder sei es vielleicht auch einmal
sondern auch lange zeit dann oder
netflix oder was auch immer hat dann
kann man sich da sicherlich schon eine
ganz gute strategie zurechtlegen aber
auch da hat es halt sehr sehr viel mit
dem eigenen glauben zu tun also glaube
ich daran dass dieses unternehmen so gut
aufgestellt dass diese krise überhaupt
zu überleben und dann geht es ja nicht
nur zu überleben sondern wir wollen ja
rendite machen dann auch wirklich hoch
zu gehen ganz ganz viele fragen
erreichen uns die relativ simpel sind
und die einfach nur wissen möchten ist
mein geld auf meinem sparbuch jetzt
sicher also es gibt die
einlagensicherung hunderttausend euro
das heißt alles was unter 100.000 euro
bis 100.000 euro ist es durch die
einlagensicherung gesichert alles was
darüber ist ist dann schon ein bisschen
riskanter das heißt das könnte ein
theoretisch weggenommen werden ganz
theoretisch könnte natürlich auch diese
einlagensicherung aufgehoben werden von
100.000 euro das war aber in der in den
letzten krisen auch nicht der fall
in der letzten großen finanzkrise ist
sowas auch nicht passiert in deutschland
das heißt wenn es um sicherheit geht
würde ich sagen vielleicht das geld auf
verschiedene konten auf tagesgeldkonten
meinetwegen verteilen so dass man diese
100.000 euro grenze nicht reicht oder
darunter ist dass man sagt okay ich
fühle mich sicher dass auch verschiedene
banken zu verteilen dann also ich sehe
meine meinung nach keine anzeichen dafür
dass wir alle demnächst enteignet werden
da muss man aber schon viel geld haben
wenn man mehrere hunderttausend euro auf
mehrere tage verteilen möchte gucken wir
mal kurz auf den bund und seine
hilfsmaßnahmen die bundesregierung hat
viel angekündigt hat viel versprochen
einmal wird mehr geld aufgenommen es
gibt eine hohe neuverschuldung um jetzt
konkret zu helfen um kleinunternehmen
selbstständigen zu helfen aber es gibt
ja auch die garantien dass kredite
gewährt werden quasi unbegrenzter höhe
das klingt jetzt erst mal beruhigend für
viele kann aber auch natürlich
spätfolgen haben für die wirtschaft und
wir haben unseren mann an der börse
frank bethmann mal gefragt was da auf
uns zukommen könnte
sie haben zumindest zunächst mal die
finanzmärkte etwas beruhigt aber man
merkt es schon in diesen tagen schon
wieder vorbei mit der ruhe war natürlich
ein klar ist solange man kein adäquates
mittel gegen dieses corona virus findet
so lange wird die wirtschaft nicht
wieder in schwung kommen und so lange
kommt auch das kapital rat nicht wieder
voll ins zum drehen
das heißt man hat mit diesen vielen
milliarden zunächst einmal zeit erkauft
mehr aber auch nicht
jetzt sei dank hat deutschland gute
jahre hinter sich das heißt man hat ein
bisschen polster angesetzt aber jeder
kann sich vorstellen dass das geld nicht
unendlich reicht und dann müssen staaten
sich eben am kapitalmarkt hier
finanzieren so genannte staatsanleihen
ausgeben und über diese
dieses instrument finanziert man sich
dann das geht sicherlich eine zeit lang
auch ganz gut aber das ist ein modell
was nicht unendlich geht weil das
natürlich auch in eine überschuldung der
staaten führt es kann zu einer
überschuldung kommen wir kriegen gerade
mit dass auch die usa in eine rezession
schlittern auf die amerikaner werden
sich am kapitalmarkt bedienen geld
aufnehmen andere staaten auch alle haben
auf einmal die note an geld zu kommen
und man kann sich vorstellen dass der
internationale kapitalmarkt nicht alle
gleich gut bedienen kann bzw die
wirtschaftlich schwächeren fallen dann
hinten rüber stehen dann möglicherweise
am rand einer pleite das haben wir alles
schon in der letzten finanzkrise erlebt
und so ist in der tat die sorge auch da
das aus der korona krise irgendwann
wieder eine finanz oder schuldenkrise
werden kann
ich habe was das für uns ganz normale
sparer und kleinanleger heißt das
bespreche ich heute mit der finanz
blockerin natascha wegelin aus berlin
die berät als madame moneypenny vor
allem frauen aber heute können alle ihre
fragen stellen packt sie weiter in die
kommentare
wir haben gerade schon gehört neue
schulden neues geld wird in den markt
gepumpt das kann natürlich auswirkungen
haben auf den geldwert hyperinflationen
ist das stichwort hier gibt es eine
frage von lustmord interessanter name
auf youtube ich habe circa vier bis
fünftausend euro gespart wie steht es um
die inflation ist mein geld in einem
jahr vielleicht nur noch die hälfte wert
ja also darum wird tatsächlich von einer
hyperinflation reden also die hälfte
schon sehr sehr viel
auch da wenn man sich mal die
inflationsraten anschaut der letzten
jahre in deutschland und entsprechend
auch die letzten crash mal mit durchgeht
da ist keine hyperinflation zustande
gekommen
ich glaube 2008 war die inflationsrate
bei 2 4% oder so und 2009 dann bei ich
glaube unter einem prozent 0 3 0 4 0 5
oder so also auch da gibt es wieder und
ich meine das war eine handfeste
finanzkrise der wahre auslöser
finanzkrise banken usw wurde auch viel
geld natürlich reingepumpt also selbst
da ist es nicht zu einer hyperinflation
gekommen
von daher aber jetzt hat es ja noch
schlimmer sein als 2008
vielleicht vielleicht steigt die
inflation dann auch ein bisschen aber so
hyperinflation das abermals gelten noch
die hälfte wert ist also da werden
zumindest sagen wir mal so werden alle
sehr viel versuchen dass es nicht dazu
kommen es gibt trotzdem immer leute die
warnen davor auch auf youtube muss man
sagen da gibt es menschen die sie quasi
immer den crash bei beschwören und dann
häufig das war auch 2008 zu ich erinnere
mich immer hieß es immer interessiert in
gold investiert in gold hier ist eine
frage von wo spiegel auf youtube mal
kurz drauf schalten
so wird würde uns ja noch zwei jahre
erhalten bleiben sagen viele experten
das dürfte für die wirtschaft sehr
schwer werden würde es sinn machen jetzt
in gold oder andere edelmetalle zu
investieren was meinen sie ist das passt
wo sie auch was rein gesteckt haben also
ich nehme
gold kommt mir sozusagen nicht ins haus
dahinter steckt ja also erstmal zu gold
gold unterliegt auch sehr sehr großen
schwankungen und hat gemessen an den
schwankungen also einem risiko dass man
da eine relativ geringe rendite also mit
aktien wenn man weltweit in aktien
investiert hätte hat man weniger
schwankungen mehreren also dass man nur
so ganz grob ganz große geld also
eigentlich eine lose lose situation am
ende
und was da natürlich dahinter steht ist
eben diese angst vor inflation zusammen
ok gold davon gibt es nur so und so
viele mängel das heißt dass begrenzt der
wert wird immer da sein
wer jetzt total angst davor hat vor der
hyperinflation und alles bricht zusammen
ja dann wenn man sich damit besser fühlt
kann man natürlich ein bisschen was an
gold kaufen wenn man den gedanken
weiterspinnen uns überlegt ok
weltuntergang ich muss jetzt gold kaufen
beim weltuntergang nützt einem das gold
ist wahrscheinlich auch nicht so super
viele taten dann andere sachwerte
nämlich immer sondern vielleicht gut
tauschen oder essen kann
zigaretten zum beispiel war ja im
zweiten weltkrieg häufig so blieb das
ich möchte das aber niemandem aufrufen
dazu dass er sein ganzes geld in
klopapier und zigaretten investiert das
glaube ich nicht die message heute wir
hatten tatsächlich in der diskussion vor
ein paar tagen bei uns in der maske wo
auch sich eine kollegin ganz besorgt
äusserte und fragte was mache ich mit
meinem geld ich hole das lieber von der
bank das war ja auch so ein effekt den
hatten wir in griechenland bei der
finanzkrise dort dass sparer hingegangen
sind und versucht haben das geld zu
holen und dann wurde das begrenzt man
durfte nur noch 100 euro
tag abheben ist das eine gute idee ist
sich jetzt das geld unters kopfkissen zu
stecken oder vielleicht ein tresor zu
kaufen und dann irgendwie im wohnzimmer
zu bunkern
also ich glaube das ist immer ganz gut
ein bisschen bargeld zu hause zu haben
das habe ich auch das ist ja mal
passieren
bei 100 euro ok also das sind jetzt
nicht die 1000 also ich würde es nicht
auf die option sparen gehe und sage
nichts sehen jetzt meine zehen 20.000
euro ab das ich glaube das ist einfach
nicht nicht notwendig wie gesagt unter
dieser 100000 euro ganze sowieso sicher
durch die einlagensicherung und auch da
wieder der gedanke ok märz in tresoren
zuhause hinzustellen das was also wenn
die welt untergeht dann haben wir andere
sachen unser geld und das sage ich
nichts mehr werde so sowie kommen mal zu
ganz konkreten fragen die sich hier
aufgetan haben also zum beispiel fragt
hier auf facebook damals baum ruck kann
meine lebensversicherung die als
altersversorgung bei einem renommierten
versicherer abgeschlossen wurde in einem
crash insolvent und damit verloren gehen
da bin ich mir ehrlich gesagt nicht so
hundertprozentig sicher wie das mit der
versicherung ist aber ich würde es
bezweifeln ehrlich gesagt dass das
überhaupt nicht abgesichert ist also da
wird es irgendeine sicherheit geben
dann gibt es fragen hierzu bitcoin zum
beispiel auf youtube für gruppen immer
drauf ist betreut etwas was man kaufen
sollte und was ist an dem gerücht dran
dass die staaten den eigenen digitalen
währungen arbeiten ich glaube bleiben
erstmal bei der bitcoin frage die kam
auch bei anderen usern hier auf das war
ja mal sehr absolut letzte heiße ich
wollte das nicht scheiß sagen ich sag's
trotzdem alle haben gefroren geht in
bitcoin und dann ist so ein bisschen
mein gefühl die blase wieder geplatzt
ist es trotzdem was sie sagen würden so
gut vielleicht ein paar prozent kann man
bitcoins halten also ich persönlich habe
es nicht auch da ist wieder die frage
was ist die idee dahinter glaube ich
daran dass das jetzt den euro ablöse als
zahlungsmittel oder soja hat
vielleicht ja wenn ich nicht der meinung
bin aber ansonsten ist bitcoin auch
gerade jetzt auch einfach hoch
spekulativ das war vor zehn jahren wenn
man dann die genug war und den braten
gerochen dann konnte man damit sehr viel
geld verdienen aber ich denke da tut es
auch einfach aktien die gerade auch
schön günstig sind und die dann immer
noch ein bisschen sicher mehr substanz
dahinter ist als in bitcoin oder
ähnliche bewegung
dann schaue ich gerade mal was wir noch
so haben eine frage die auch häufig auf
kam tatsächlich immobilienpreise und
haus kaufen zum beispiel aus rahm feier
auf youtube fragte das ist in berlin auf
youtube auch sollte ich mir jetzt also
manche planen dass er sowieso schon und
haben jetzt ein haus hinaus nicht oder
wollten das kaufen ist das ist eine gute
idee in immobilien zu investieren
also ich denke wenn das sowieso der plan
war also ich merke schon dass die leute
ein bisschen zögerliche sind genau bei
solchen geschichten ist bin ich aber
auch in ordnung weil dann lieber noch
mal durchrechnen und auch mal den worst
case durch rechnen wenn die zinsen
steigen
und da lieber noch mal reingehen und
vielleicht ein bisschen pessimistischer
durchrechnen ob wir uns das wirklich
wirklich wirklich wirklich leisten
können und ansonsten würde ich sagen ja
geht also da auch da gibt es keine
großartigen anzeige zumindest aktuell
dass da ein riesengroßer crash uns blüht
aber auch das kann man nicht so richtig
vorher sehen also meine empfehlung wäre
vorsichtig an die sache ranzugehen aber
ist jetzt auch nicht komplett zu
überwerfen wenn das sowieso jetzt der
langfristige plan war
gleichzeitig kam auch eine frage auf auf
instagram von digi land nie was war eine
andere frage ist rockies mama war das
und her sind 77 die wollten wissen sie
wollten ihr haus verkaufen ob das heißt
eine gute idee ist weil die
immobilienpreise können jetzt wieder
runter gehen weil viele leute doch nicht
mehr so viel geld haben sind in
kurzarbeit dann kann man sich nicht so
viel kredit leisten die banken können
nicht mehr so viele kredite vergeben und
dann merken die menschen die im haus
haben okay ich krieg doch nicht mehr so
viel kohle ist es jetzt ein guter
zeitpunkt weil die preise fallen könnten
ja gute frage ist natürlich ist alles
hoch spekulative klar könnten die preise
fallen die frage so ein bisschen was ist
das war meine idee mit dieser immobilie
würde ich da eigentlich lieber noch
gerne daran weiter wohnt die nächsten 30
jahre oder bin ich jetzt so auf der
kippe und sagt eigentlich wie schon seit
fünf jahren verkaufen und jetzt denke
ich das ist so der letzte acht da will
ich nochmal ganz klar unterscheiden also
nur weil jetzt die immobilienpreise
sinken könnten in den nächsten zwei
jahren keine zusagen oder jetzt
verkaufen und schnell das haus also
eigentlich vielleicht gar nicht
verkaufen wollen würde ich auch sehr
vorsichtig rangehen als ich glaube angst
und gier sind immer sehr schlechte
berater in allem was mit geld
entscheidungen zu tun hat und jetzt
herrscht natürlich viel angst viel
unsicherheit und da kann ich nur
appellieren tätig rationale
entscheidungen zu treffen und nicht so
viel dieses jahr was ist wenn was ist
wenn es in einem jahr so kommt oder so
kommt ja und was wenn es dann anders
kommt dann steht man auch wieder da
also lieber in szenarien denken
vorbereitet sein und so dass man dann
schnell reagieren kann wenn gewisse
kriterien sich denn dann bewahrheiten
eine frage die sich auch häufig gestellt
wurde ist sparpläne es gibt ja menschen
die investieren einfach jeden monat 23
400 500 euro in ihre sparpläne das geht
es dann erst mal gebunden für zehn 20 30
jahre
da kommt man nicht ran sollte man jetzt
versuchen diese summe bis hin zu
minimieren
also bei den sparplänen kommt man ja
daran dass andere versicherung da kommt
man nicht raus also da lässt sich jetzt
aber auch nicht wenn das eine
rentenversicherung ist ja was natürlich
passieren könnte ist dass der dass der
zins dass der garantiezins bei den
rentenversicherungen bisschen sinkt
jetzt gerade ist er aber auch irgendwann
0,9 prozent also das sie kein werkzeug
um vermögen aufzubauen da wüsste ich
nicht warum man jetzt eine
rentenversicherung auflösen sollte es ja
das schöne an sondern versicherung die
zahl zahl zahlt egal was kommt im besten
fall und ansonsten aktien sparpläne etf
sparplänen das ist ja wie so eine art
dauerauftrag genau gesagt ist also 100
200 euro gibt auf 25 euro geht schon los
monatlich immer schön investieren da
kann ich auch jederzeit dran
jetzt ist natürlich aber jetzt laute die
devise eben das nicht zu stoppen und
nicht den sparbetrag runterzuschrauben
oder nicht das geld raus zu nehmen weil
jetzt gerade ist wie gesagt schön
günstig das heißt ich bekomme für meine
sparrate von beispielsweise 100 euro
mehr anteile an meinem etf fordern in
aktien
weil die preise gerade unten sind das
heißt jetzt ist eigentlich eine gute
zeit das auszunutzen günstig einzukaufen
dann habe ich mehr anteile die dann
hinterher an wert gewinnen auf lange
zeit wenn wir mal in die zukunft gucken
da gibt es verschiedene szenarien wie
sich das weiter entwickeln könnte wir
haben gerade drei jetzt noch diskutiert
von den wirtschaftsweisen die sagen das
kann relativ schnell runter gehen aber
es will erholt sich wieder
ist das was woran sie sich orientieren
und sagen okay da da setze ich darauf
auf solche empfehlungen oder was ist ihr
ihre empfehlung für man jetzt in die
zukunft gucken sollte ja also wie ich
das gerne mache ist ich gucke mir gerne
andere krisen an und da gibt es sehr
schöne statistiken sehr schöne auch
relativ genaue zeiten die letzte krise
beispielsweise da war es so dass an den
finanzmärkten an den aktienmärkten der
tiefpunkt nach ungefähr einem jahr oder
im jahr und zwei monate erreicht war
wenn man da jetzt die schablone
drauflegen seit dieses jahr dieses mal
könnte es ähnlich sein dann haben sie
also noch einen kleinen reformen aber
egal wie lange das jetzt dauert ob es
eine oder zwei oder fünf jahre dauert
ich glaube ganz fest daran an unserer
wirtschaft und zwar nicht nur die
deutsche sondern die komplette
weltwirtschaft und bis jetzt krisen
gehören einfach dazu
ja also bei davon jetzt immer noch
überrascht ist es nicht von hennig
letzten jahre war
krisen gehören mit dazu da gehört es
auch dazu da durchzugehen und deswegen
investiere ich ja beispielsweise auch
sehr sehr langfristig um eben genau
diese vorübergehenden verluste dann
wieder wettmachen zu können über die
zeit also ja ich glaube da kann also
ganz also hundertprozentig wird wird
unsere wirtschaften die vom erdboden
verschluckt und alle unternehmen pleite
und wir haben fangen wieder an mit
schafen zu handeln
das hoffe ich zumindest ich wüsste nicht
wo ich hier aufbewahren sollte zumindest
zurzeit vielen dank frau w gelehnt für
ihre tipps und für ihre ratschläge
ich hoffe wir konnten viele von euren
fragen beantworten ich nehme das mal mit
aus dem gespräch mit ihnen
entspannt bleiben und nicht in panik
verfallen weil die anzeichen sehen zwar
ist nicht so super rosig aus aber es
sieht doch nicht nach dem kompletten
crash aus denen manche doch immer
befürchten ich sage vielen dank nach
berlin ich seit vielen dank für eure
fragen und kommentare und wir sehen uns
morgen wieder im nächsten corona
sprechstunden livestream hier bei uns
20.30 bis dahin sage ich und tschüss
[Musik]